[Musique]
laissez moi vous raconter quand j'étais
petit j'avais presque le même bateau
tous les étés ans se baladait sur le lac
y avait de l'amour
nous étions en famille ont passé des
moments merveilleux ont coulé en voiture
c'est pas vrai il d'un coup j'ai mis
quelque chose qui vous tient ça ne plaît
fais pas ça
ce n'est ni un virus ni une attaque
chimique c'est le mal absolu
ils ont vu des créatures qui peuvent
prendre la forme de ce qu'on redoute le
plus à chaque fois qu'on entre en
contact avec l'extérieur
il y a des morts
est venu me chercher pour me recevez à
l'eau nous avons un endroit c'est un
lieu sûr pour nous rejoindre il faut
descendre la rivière les oiseaux vous
avertirons chaque fois que ces choses
s'apaiseront
on va devoir partir non
mais n'enlevez jamais vauban temps
s'en sortir
[Musique]
pour les enfants et partez
je vais pas te laisser tout seul
prenez pas mes enfants non non non non
je parle à mes enfants
les foules
maintenant